we are in the town of san jose in the
nagat province
everywhere we look there is devastation
this coastal community has been
completely damaged by typhoon rai we've
spoken to residents who are now forced
to sleep by the roadside because their
homes have been completely destroyed
we've been told we were the first
journalists to ever visit this community
a community that remains cut off from
the rest of the world there is debris
everywhere and people are forced to just
pick up the pieces they say they have
yet to see any government official they
have yet to receive any aid whatsoever
and the situation is quite desperate but
what we're seeing is just a fraction of
the devastation brought about by typhoon
rice fury there are at least five
provinces deeply affected by this
typhoon affecting millions of people the
government says it is doing the best it
can to send aid to those who need it
most especially those who live in
islands like this one but we spoke to
people here who say they are very
disappointed about the government
response and they feel abandoned and
they say even though they can't pick up
the pieces it's not going to be easy
because it also means that it will take
many many months before they can even
feel a semblance of normalcy again